aj we've talked to a lot of actors
who've
revealed to us that the cinematographer
is the one who
sort of sees their truth okay
and you guys have the ability to see
them in ways that they can't see
themselves you know we're all kind of
stuck in our own world we only see what
we think we're projecting
how do you experience this with them
what if you see them in another way
that's not their brand but you think
that's beneficial to the project or
their role
yeah i mean i think that's kind of goes
along with what i was talking about
before with the directing aspect and how
i like to be close to the actors
inevitably as a cinematographer i'm
always like right next to the actor or
i'm
you know
standing over them or you know whatever
right next to them with a camera and i'm
you know
sometimes breathing down their neck
basically
um
and i definitely get a
upfront view of what their performance
is a lot of time
and
i guess i know enough about the actors
that i have a knowledge of their history
and their their
brand as you call it
but i'm always open to
to new things and i think
when i notice something that an actor is
doing and i think it's great i'll let
them know that and i'll try to grab it
with the camera and i think i think they
appreciate that um and they like
knowing that someone is paying attention
and someone is appreciating as well like
what they're offering to the film
and if i can do that and if i can make
an actor feel like they want to give the
most because of that that's i think my
job is already done better than i can
possibly hope for
and if i can also make it look rad while
i'm at it that's even better
but
you know
i've worked with a lot of good act
really great actors and one of the
things i do
like about it is it's a team effort they
know what i'm doing
the really great actors know what the
camera is doing
and they will tailor their performance
a lot of times to what the frame is
they may not
accept being held in a small space by a
camera
but they can appreciate a shot if it's a
close-up for example they can bring they
can they move within that frame really
well a lot of times and
you know it's a dance it's like a it's
like having a really good dance partner
and when when you're doing well it kind
of promotes even
more positive
dancing you know maybe they'll go an
extra mile with a certain move that they
normally wouldn't do or
they'll feel confident enough or they'll
feel free enough to be able to go
somewhere
with with a performance or a scene that
they might not have been able to do if
they didn't feel like they were being
captured appropriately
so
i think that's one of my strong points
as a cinematographer i would say is that
i can i can say that i really pay
attention to the actors and i think i
try to make them feel like they are
being paid attention to and that
whatever they're doing is getting
captured right and
it tends to get people
to to put their best foot forward
whatever that is and it not necessarily
has to be their brand
it can be something new that they're
wanting to try or
you know
whatever their character is calling for
they can commit to a little bit more
because of it